a last hello before a fond farewell to
North America William and Kate drop in
on la's Skid Row 10,000 children passed
through the doors of this project each
year together the Duke and Duchess of
Cambridge have used this tour to help
those post inland the last of dozens of
engagements over the past 11 days was
reserved for the US military at
Hollywood's Sony Studios a jobs fair for
former servicemen and women this is an
officer who needs no introduction His
Royal Highness the Duke of Cambridge
Katherine I both our friends back in
Britain who could get benefits for a
brilliant initiative like this I'm
delighted therefore that our foundation
and in that I include my loaf like Hoshi
very average brother and the partner in
today's events with this jobs fair its
job done for William and Kate as their
first official overseas tour comes to an
end but this really is just seen one in
this new royal relationship there'll be
lights cameras and plenty more action to
come such has been the success of this
tour Hollywood's newest stars won't
disappear for long Paul Harrison Sky
News Los Angeles